so great to have you I'm genuinely
excited I might say that quite a lot
it's fantastic to see so many of you in
the room here today for what I promise
is going to be a brilliant couple of
days for those of you I haven't met yet
I'm Simon classy Eldridge Chief campaign
director at the CBI and I'm going to be
spending the next two days with you as
your conference host which given what my
job is is slightly more than I've
managed to say to my family at all in
the last few months
so normally my days are spent trying to
work out what the goings-on in
Westminster mean for all of you in the
room but in these times have changed
today I thought I'd give hosting a go
and I have already decided to all the
broadcasters in the room that I will not
be giving up my day job
uh I'm genuinely excited as I said I am
excited about my first CBI annual
conference and the first we've done in
person for three whole years
and I asked the team before I came here
for a little bit of advice as to how how
am I going to get through this and they
said plenty of caffeine I have done that
comfy shoes done that and I came up with
my own which is perhaps some slightly
more predictable headlines than we had
last year
and I was told that this was going to be
big but I really wasn't expecting this
and my ask of all of you is that you
make the most of the next two days and
you really enjoy yourselves and of
course none of this would be possible
without the support of our strategic
Partners Accenture and Haze so I'm going
to ask you all to give them a big round
of applause
so we have put together a very packed
agenda for the next two days but I'm
just going to get something cleared up
because I've been informed that there is
another big event happening today
so please rest assured that if you do
want to watch the football we are going
to be playing it yes Simon right here on
this massive screen behind us so you can
get your lunch you can bring it back and
you can watch some football and I think
after this morning's speeches there's
quite a few of us who are going to be
keeping a very close eye on Sterling
thanks Pete
so getting back to business over the
course over the next two days you'll be
hearing from some of the leading
thinkers around the UK from politics
business and much much more and I don't
think that I'm giving away too much by
saying we're going to be talking a lot
about growth how to plan for it how to
remove barriers to it and how to go for
growth
we at the CBI have been talking about
pretty much nothing else for the last
two years so this will come as no
surprise
with all the challenges we're facing it
has never been more important and
finally almost all of our sessions have
time for questions so make sure you
start thinking about those now
without further Ado let's get started I
would like to welcome onto the stage the
cbi's very own Mr growth our director
General Tony danker
[Applause]
good morning everybody good morning and
welcome to the fabulous city of
Birmingham today we oh some people from
Birmingham uh anybody else from the
Midlands
yeah okay uh that that's the end of the
uh of the sort of Christmas fun I'm
afraid uh look today we are going to
bring you television
we're going to bring you economic Vision
but we just couldn't bring you
Eurovision sorry that went to Liverpool
but what a city and what a region still
buzzing from The Summer's Olympic Games
the Midlands is home to some of the UK's
most successful firms and Cutting Edge
Industries and I'm thrilled that we'll
be joined later by the mayor of the West
Midlands and history a man who has not
only brought real leadership to this
city but also in his prior job he always
paid his CBI invoice on time
let that be a lesson to everybody in
this room the greatness you get from
doing so look we've got to pack few days
ahead of us as Simon said with business
experts to inform us political leaders
to inspire us and an England World Cup
to remind us that it's always the hope
that kills
but don't worry we can all be Wales fans
later now this year I'm also joined by
Brian McBride the cbi's new president
attending his first annual conference in
the role now he may be a Scotland
supporter and I may be a northern
Irishman but we're hoping to bring you
wealth of knowledge and experience and
wisdom and you'll be hearing more from
Brian tomorrow alongside the leader of
the opposition gear starmer
this morning we're really delighted to
have the prime minister with us and I
know I speak for many of you when I say
how much I admired the way Rishi sunak
stood by his beliefs this summer despite
the political cost and it's a trait that
we saw working with him as Chancellor he
is a man of integrity and conviction and
in our time working together I always
found him to be warm to be frank and to
be a genuine partner for business in
government
and he takes the role at a most
challenging time and while we won't
always agree with him we will always
support his Endeavor to First stabilize
and then to grow our economy so it's a
pleasure to be the warm-up act for the
Prime Minister this morning
I also want to thank our strategic
Partners Accenture and Hayes whose
long-standing collaboration and wisdom
we value greatly they keep coming back
for more every year despite Peppa Pig
and we love having them and I also want
to thank our other corporate Partners
Phoenix group related Argent shell and
Visa we are incredibly grateful for
their support not just as sponsors but
as members all of these businesses and
many of you in the room have a great
story to tell about the potential and
the transformation of the UK economy
now we come together
once more in extraordinary times
Britain is in the middle of stagflation
rocketing inflation and negative growth
for the first time that probably most of
us in this room can remember now we know
how to fight inflation right and we know
how to fight recession
but we don't really know how to fight
them together
and the predictable reaction when we
confront stagflation
is to choose which evil is worse but
that just leads to different kinds of
problem
if you ignore inflation to get growth
going we've seen what happens you get
immediate trauma
but if you ignore growth to get
inflation down you get prolonged pain
and I just reject the idea that you have
to choose I say you don't choose
aggressively getting inflation down is
the right thing to do especially after
the Market's response to the mini budget
Market stability is a precondition to
growth that's what all of you told me
these past few weeks and I pay tribute
to the Prime Minister and the chancellor
for taking the tough choices needed to
achieve it
but what about growth
the painful reality about growth is that
it can be stimulated overnight that's
what the mini budget got wrong
right across-the-board tax cuts
immediate demand stimulus it was relying
on the old British strength consumption
at the expense of The Perennial British
weakness investment
and it gave growth a bad name
but growth is good
growth is a precondition to a stable
Society without growth the NHS gets
worse not better without growth people's
lives get worse not better and without
growth we lack the resources we need to
transform ourselves to a zero carbon
world
yet Britain's had 15 years
of low growth and flatlining
productivity and we cannot afford a
repeat of that to the Chancellor's
credit he does know the importance of
growth and last week he made some
incredibly welcome announcements
first on business rates relief something
we've been campaigning on since the 16th
century
and it didn't take us that long and he's
staying the course on vital
infrastructure from sizewell C hs2 East
West Rail and Northern Powerhouse rail
but you know even with these projects
the obr's forecast concluded that the
statement will not alter Britain's Trend
growth of 1.7 percent
Trend growth if you don't know what it
is is a statement of the true growth
rate of an economy without the
variations of inflation and not only has
the obr not changed its assessment of
our Trend growth since March lower
forecasts for investment lower forecast
for productivity are dragging us down
in fact when you look at the data the
only thing holding it up actually is
higher R's work due to higher
immigration
now you know people are arguing against
immigration but it's the only thing
that's increased our growth potential
since March
look if you want to talk about growth
you have to remember mathematically it's
very simple right GDP growth is a
multiplier of two factors people and
their productivity
and let's be honest we don't have the
people we need nor do we have the
productivity
people are returned to in a minute
but as for productivity it is something
that I have worked on my whole adult
life and you know I've rarely seen a
better prospectus for what we need than
the prime minister's own maze lecture
earlier this year his Central thesis
that without stimulating investment in
capital people and ideas we won't
improve productivity
well the Prime Minister was right
but these proposals did not come to
fruition in last week's plan
look I don't think I'm going to need to
work hard to convince any of you in this
room that we need to go for growth but
we all need to consider a very new
reality
when fiscal policy is tight and it must
be
when monetary policy is tight and it
must be how do you get the economy
growing again that is the central
question of British economics and
politics now for the next two years
look it's a hard one and if I'm honest
it might take us all some time to get
the answer right might take sitting
around the Christmas campfire with a bit
of Sherry before we can really start to
reflect on how to do this but I thought
I'd have a go by laying out a few ideas
this morning
you know in May 2021 the CBI said I had
a vision for the UK economy I hope you
remember it it had as its destination a
more competitive Dynamic and future
focused economy
now achieving all that without the Boost
of Public Finance requires fresh
thinking these next five years as I said
we're out of Road on both fiscal and
monetary support so we have to find a
new Avenue round
I believe there's three ways to do it
three imperatives one of them is for
everybody in this room the others are
for Rishi sunak kierstarmer and the
politicians the first is greater
business Ingenuity right we are the ones
who'll get this done we in this room you
guys entrepreneurs business owners
growing businesses multinationals in the
past two years you have shown more
resilience imagination bravery and
Agility than ever
and the bad news is you cannot take a
break
greater business Ingenuity has to become
the new normal for UK plc
but second we need government to be the
great unlocker of private sector
investment you the government or the
market mover you the government direct
the flow of traffic the tax incentives
you set determine where businesses
invest the risks you underwrite actually
create new markets if we have less
public money to invest then we need a
treasury obsessed with stimulating
private sector investment
and third we need government to set
pro-growth rules not anti-growth
barriers you the government decide what
we regulate and what we don't you decide
the skills we import or don't you decide
where we build or where we don't you
decide who we trade with and who we
don't
today let's be honest none of those
rules really work for growth because
politicians were able to rely on fiscal
Firepower they didn't have to make those
tough choices
well they can't be avoided any longer
let me first come back to business
Ingenuity this is a bit between all of
us right let me tell you why you should
invest right now
UK PLC has not begun to realize the 700
billion pounds in prizes that we
identified for 2030 in our Landmark
Vision last year seized the moment let
me give you some of the examples just in
case you forgot uh take decarbonization
where the UK can genuinely be the winner
in the global race to Net Zero we can
genuinely be Market leaders in Green
Tech and clean energy and we can be the
global Center for sustainable Finance
or innovation where the UK can push what
we've seen in the last couple of years
which is a lead in science and
technology with increased Global share
for UK fintech for example or leveraging
our domestic AI expertise
on trade
there is so much untapped expert revenue
for us by pressing our advantages in the
high growth Global markets in regions
and Nations we can win Global share by
playing to the distinctive strengths of
every region and every part of the UK we
think as you know the path to this is
clusters something I'm delighted to say
the chancellor got behind last week
when it comes to Workforce we are all
getting are we not really serious about
Talent from Recruitment and Retention to
training and we'll be talking about that
more today and in health
employers are a new front line in
physical and mental well-being and we
have the potential to grow life sciences
and wellness sectors massively
now this is the growth potential of
Britain
six prizes still very much in our reach
and last year we saw it in the
statistics well this year we've seen it
in your stories there is so much to play
for
now the second imperative is for
government
unlocking private sector investment you
know the government spends one trillion
pounds per year now I'd love it to spend
20 billion more with a higher return in
fact I have some plans but the nice man
Jeremy said no but still it's one
billion one trillion pounds a year and
there are still massive choices for
government to make without spending the
first choice is about the principles of
business taxation
when the prime minister is chancellor
told me that he was announcing the super
deduction alongside the increase in
corporation tax the principle was very
clear if you as a firm choose to invest
less and make a bigger profit that is
your choice
but you'll pay more tax
if you choose instead to invest in
people Capital ideas then you'll pay
less
you know corporation tax rates will jump
six points overnight in April but now
without the incentives but that
principle should be staying the same
our analysis shows us that a permanent
full allowances regime alongside that
jump would unlock an extra 50 billion
pounds in capital investment every year
by the end of the decade
and the second choice here is for the
government to start using their balance
sheet to crowd in private sector
investment I'm not talking about
government picking winners I'm talking
about the government making markets like
they did in offshore wind it was private
sector Ingenuity and skills and money
that built the industry but it took the
government to put in place the finance
models like contracts for difference and
the investment bodies to make this a
highly investable Market
and we can do it again in sustainable
Aviation fuels in hydrogen you see this
is the power of government as a market
mover seeing the market sharing the risk
and creating investable propositions
the third imperative is the government
setting pro-growth rules
our politicians make anti-growth choices
every day in pursuit of other legitimate
political goals and I respect that
but when we confront stagflation and its
massive impact on the cost of living I
think it's time to kick the tires on
those political choices
let me give you some examples
immigration
let's be honest with people our labor
shortages are vast
now we've lost hundreds of thousands of
people to economic inactivity post
covert and anyone who thinks they'll all
be back any day now with the NHS under
this kind of pressure is killing
themselves
secondly we don't have enough Brits to
go around for the vacancies that exist
let alone having a skill mismatch in any
case
and third those who argue automation can
step in to do all the jobs are just
being unrealistic
so let's be practical let's have a new
deal on immigration we have economic
migration in the areas where we aren't
going to get the people of the skills at
home anytime soon
in return we make those visas fixed term
and let's agree a skills policy that
works to fill these roles in the medium
term
I want to shortage occupation list that
not only goes to the minister of edu the
minister of immigration it goes to the
Secretary of State for education
and it goes to all of us to make sure we
partner with the ministry for education
on training budgets
let me give you another political
example regulation
I know that some conservative
politicians today feel that this issue
is all the fault of Europe
but you know the biggest regulatory
barriers facing business today are based
on British laws created by a British
Parliament and implemented by British
regulators and the regulatory regime
today is gold-plated and bureaucratic
it's not outcomes based it's rules-based
it's not proportionate it winds us all
up in an overzealous process of
enforcement and too many Regulators
still think it's somebody else's job to
worry about growth and investment
here's another favorite planning the UK
planning system should be a key economic
enabler helping us to get the essential
infrastructure and major projects
required and yet in Britain today
planning is broken we've been saying it
for years and it's gotten worse slow
fragmented Rife with local politics and
if we don't do it now then when are we
ever going to change it
and finally trade right now our trade as
a percentage of GDP is the lowest in the
G7
now Boris Johnson achieved a deal with
the EU that allows us to continue to
trade tariff free quota free with our
biggest trading partner there's some
good stuff in there currently locked up
because still we argue over the Northern
Ireland protocol both sides
still we argue over sovereignty
so I say to both sides get round the
table do the deal and unlock the trading
cooperation agreement
and I say to brexiteers the best
guarantor of brexit is an economy that
grows and its biggest risk is one that
doesn't
now I know that some of these things
won't be that popular with the
politicians
but while I have no problem with
government taking tough choices to bring
stability I want them to also take tough
choices to bring growth
so look this is day one of a discussion
we're going to be having for the next
two years friends how the UK grows when
our fiscal and monetary policy shrinks
government may not have new money
but they do have lots of choices and
until they take them we'll keep pushing
and you are members the wealth creators
who pay the salaries make the cars build
the wind turbines Finance the loans sell
the food print the textbooks we also ask
you
to build on the greater resilience you
find in the pandemic to build on the
business confidence you've had these two
years and still have to extend your
Ingenuity for growth
just like you did two years ago when the
economy closed down
because no one ever got up a hill by
taking their foot off the accelerator
this isn't a moment to fear it's a
moment to seize growth gives everyone a
path out of difficult times and it is
what will make the UK the most
competitive Dynamic and future focused
economy that we want it to be
the CBI will be with you every step of
the way so let's go for growth together
thanks very much indeed
[Applause]
it's tough again
energy costs inflation interest rates
politics
you won't be human if you didn't pause
hesitate
but no one got up a hill by taking the
foot off the accelerator
and against all the odds you've got some
momentum
demand's not bad
there are still good things to invest in
new Services new tech new customers
this isn't a moment's fear it's a moment
to seize
you'll have to be resilient fitting off
but if you're as good as we think you
are you can grow
th lifts everyone
it keeps everyone in good shape gives us
all a path out of difficult times
so let's go for growth
together
okay folks it now gives me enormous
pleasure to welcome back to the CBI now
with a promotion the Prime Minister the
right honorable Rishi sunak
thank you very good to see you
saw yours
well Tony let me start by saying thank
you to you and your team the CBI is a
valued institution in this country and a
powerful voice for business
and let me thank all of you
because I know things are tough right
now
you rightly want to know what you can
expect from me
you saw What mattered to me as
Chancellor with policies like furlough
acting with empathy in the National
interest
above all
being bold
decisive
and radical
now
let me tell you what I want to do as
prime minister
I said on the steps of Downing Street
that I would put stability and
confidence at the heart of this
government's agenda
and last week
we did that with a plan to grip
inflation and balance the books
I said I will bring fairness and
compassion to help the most vulnerable
and we've done that too not just with
record increases and pensions and
Welfare
and help for People's Energy bills but
by controlling inflation
because the best way to help people
is by stopping mortgages rents and food
prices from spiraling out of control
re-establishing stability
is the critical first step
but there's so much more we need to do
I'm not just here to solve problems
I Want to Build a Better country
where we get inflation down and grow the
economy
where we cut NHS waiting times and
improve the quality of care
and where we invest more in schools and
give every child a world-class education
and critical
to achieving all this
is innovation
that's my theme today and
a defining focus of this government
I sometimes worry that when people hear
the word Innovation all they think of
are the latest gadgets a smarter watch
better TV or faster car
but to me
Innovation is much more about new ideas
new ways of doing things that drive
economic and social progress
the product of creativity and Ingenuity
and what Roosevelt called bold
persistent experimentation
I want to lead a country where that
mindset and that culture of innovation
permeates every aspect of what we do
whereas at the heart of our economic
policy and at the heart of our vision
for public services
the question is
how do we do that
first we need to harness Innovation to
drive economic growth
second
we need to embed innovation in our
Public Services especially our NHS
third
we need to teach people the skills to
become great innovators
first growth now Tony you've rightly
challenged us to be ambitious for growth
well
there's one factor above all that drives
growth
over the last 50 years Innovation was
responsible for around half of the UK's
productivity increases
but the rate of increase has slowed
significantly since the financial crisis
this difference explains almost all our
productivity gap for the United States
so how do we fire up the Innovation
engine
we believe that the very Act of
creativity and exploration is itself a
reward
so it starts with government investment
in basic science and research
in a challenging time when we are making
difficult decisions on public spending
in last week's Autumn statement we
protected the budget for research and
development
20 billion pounds almost a fifth of our
entire capital budget the highest level
of r d this country has ever seen
and we're investing in high risk High
reward research with the new Advanced
research and invention agency
but more important than what government
does
is what you do
it's private sector innovations that
really Drive growth now you'd expect me
to say that I'm a conservative but it's
true and that's why the Autumn statement
cut taxes to encourage larger companies
to do more research and development
it's why we want to allow businesses to
claim r d tax relief on pure maths and
cloud computing
and it's why we're absolutely committed
to using our new brexit freedoms to
create the most pro-innovation
regulatory environment in the world in
sectors like life sciences Financial
Services Ai and data
but any credible strategy also needs to
support fast growing businesses those
firms disproportionately responsible for
our future growth
turning million pound businesses into
billion pound businesses and turning
billion pound businesses into 10 billion
pound companies
we'll create good well-paid jobs for the
British people
but too often those firms can't access
the finance they need
that's why we're radically reforming the
regulation of our insurance and pension
sectors as well as our listing rules to
release a flood of new funding for
exciting Innovative businesses and will
need to go further
but this isn't just about what large
businesses and financial markets can do
we want to support small businesses to
innovate too
on every High Street
in every Market town every day
we rely on brilliant local businesses
from the green grocer to the dry cleaner
to the local plumber
we should be ambitious for their future
too
the real prize is supporting them to
innovate
and that's exactly what we're doing with
new initiatives like help to grow and
made smarter
so make no mistake our most pressing
task when it comes to growth is
stability and controlling inflation
but that will never be the limit of our
ambition
the more we innovate the more we will
grow and we have a plan for both
now second we also need to create a
culture of innovation in our Public
Services
now I grew up in an NHS family it's in
my blood
and as your prime minister I will always
protect an NHS free at the point of use
and that's why
in a budget where we had to make savings
overall
we didn't cut the funding for Health and
Social care we increased it by 8 billion
pounds
so let no one ever doubt our commitment
to the brilliant men and women who work
in our NHS
but our ambition
for our country's most important public
service
cannot be measured solely by the money
we spend but by the quality of care
every patient receives
we all want it to be easier for people
to see their family GP
we don't want our loved ones waiting so
long for ambulances or for the
operations they need
but better care requires innovation
now impart that means new drugs and new
technologies and this country should be
proud of how we are leading the way
not just with the extraordinary covet
vaccine but with robots assisting
surgery doctors being trained with
virtual reality headsets and drones
transporting prescription medicines to
patients in remote locations
and medical Technologies like these
are only the most visible form of
innovation
but we also need to radically innovate
how we do things
That's How we'll really improve the
quality and speed of care and make the
money we invest in the NHS go further
to do that we're opening Community
diagnostic Centers to deliver Millions
more tests checks and scans close to
home and without having to arrange
multiple appointments
and our new elective surgical hubs will
offer hundreds of thousands of patients
quicker access to the most common
procedures
but we need to go further still
we want to give patients genuine choice
about where and when to access care
and those choices need to be informed by
radical transparency about the
performance of our health care System
we're also making sure the NHS has the
workforce it needs for the future with
the right number of doctors and nurses
in the right places as well as thinking
creatively about what new roles and
capabilities we need in the healthcare
Workforce of the future
when it comes to the NHS we all share
the same ambition to give everybody in
the country the best possible care free
at the point of use
but to deliver it we need to be bold and
radical in challenging conventional
wisdom and that's what we will do
now third
there can be no innovation unless people
have the skills to innovate
that starts with our scores so last week
we announced an extra two billion pounds
in each of the next two years
but funding is not enough
there is no responsibility as prime
minister that I feel more deeply than
how we develop a truly world-class
education system giving every child in
our country the best chance of life and
preparing them to enter a rapidly
changing world
the times were right to challenge us
about what that looks like
and we are asking ourselves
radical searching questions
about the curriculum
because young people need to enter the
modern economy equipped with the right
Knowledge and Skills
and about technology
because we want to help children engage
and learn better and save teachers time
we also need to end once and for all
this mistaken idea that learning is
something you finish at 18. so we will
also deliver our lifetime skills
guarantee to help people of any age
retrain and acquire new skills
I believe in the very core of my being
that education is the closest thing we
have to a silver bullet in public policy
it is the most transformative thing that
we can do for our people
something you as employers know all too
well
and I am determined to get this right
but to make this country a true island
of innovation we also need to attract
the best and the brightest from around
the world
so we will unapologetically create one
of the world's most attractive visa
regimes for entrepreneurs and highly
skilled people
and one of the areas we need to be most
ambitious it's AI artificial
intelligence
because this isn't just a new technology
it's a general purpose technology like
the invention of the steam engine and
the computer chip with the potential to
transform every aspect of Our Lives
so we cannot allow the world's top AI
talent to be drawn to America or China
that's why building on the AI
scholarships and Masters conversion
courses I instigated as Chancellor
we are launching a new program to
identify and attract the world's top 100
young talents on AI
let's build it and they will come and
more let them come and they will build
it
but we must be honest with ourselves
part of the reason we ended the free
movement of labor was to rebuild public
consent in our immigration system
if we're going to have a system that
allows businesses to access the best and
brightest from around the world
we need to do more to give the British
people trust and confidence that the
system works and is fair
that means tackling illegal migration
and that's what I am determined to do
so to conclude
Innovation matters
it matters because it creates more jobs
higher wages and better opportunities
for people it matters because it
improves our schools and NHS
and over the long term by boosting
growth and creating more productive
Public Services Innovation is how we
will cut taxes for people and businesses
that's why I'm placing Innovation at the
heart of my governing agenda
and despite the challenges we face I'm
optimistic about the future
because the golden thread of our
national story has always been
innovation
the idea that what's yet to be
discovered is surely even greater than
all that's come before
I want the United Kingdom to be a place
of learning Discovery and Imagination
of potential realized and ambition
fulfilled
That's How we'll improve the lives of
all our people
and as your prime minister
that's what I'm going to do
thank you
thank you I think we're going to take
some questions from the media as we
start with the BBC
[Music]
thank you prime minister Simon Jack BBC
News um we know that chronic labor
shortages and weak post-brexit trade are
holding economic growth back you heard
this morning businesses are saying we
need looser immigration rules and closer
ties with our biggest Market the EU are
you listening to them
country's number one priority right now
when it comes to migration is tackling
illegal migration it's stopping people
coming here illegally on small boats
across the channel because when people
see that happening it undermines trust
in the system
it doesn't seem fair that people are
able to break the rules and that's what
I'm absolutely determined to fix
now I want to be honest it's not a
simple problem to solve we can't solve
it overnight but I am determined to
reduce the number of illegal migrants
coming here we started making progress
on that my conversations with President
macron enabled us to conclude a new deal
with the French to help us better police
the channel put more people working
together with the French in France but
there's more work that we need to do and
the country should be reassured that I
will tackle this as one of my highest
priorities
and if we're doing that
then I do believe that we can that it's
right to ensure that the United Kingdom
is a beacon for the world's best and
brightest from around the world you
heard me talk about that in the speech I
want to make sure that we can win the
global race for talent and I'm
Unapologetic about wanting to deliver an
immigration system which is highly
competitive for the best and the
brightest and that's what we'll deliver
but I think the most pressing priority
right now is tackling a legal migration
and that's what I'm determined to fix
next ITV
hi prime minister um
Harry Horton from ITB news we've heard
the director of the CBI say that there
is a shortage of workers at the moment
and we need a new deal on immigration
last Friday your Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
he said he wants to see the vast
majority of trade barriers with the EU
removed how are you going to change our
relationship with the EU on legal
immigration and on trade in order to
boost growth there's so many businesses
at this conference say they want to see
yeah
well thank you I think on on migration
I'd I'd point back to what I've just
said Harry but on on trade let me be
unequivocal about this under my
leadership the United Kingdom will not
pursue any relationship with Europe that
relies on alignment with EU laws now I
voted for brexit I believe in brexit and
I know that brexit can deliver and is
already delivering enormous benefits and
opportunities for the country
migration being an immediate one where
we have proper control of our borders
and are able to have a conversation with
a country about the type of migration
that we want to need right we weren't
able to do that inside the European
Union at least now we are in control of
it when it comes to trade it means that
we can open up our country to the
world's fastest growing markets I've
just got back from the G20 in Indonesia
we're talking about signing cptpp where
we've got some of the most exciting
fastest growing economies in the world
and we can become a part of that trading
blog that's a fantastic opportunity for
the UK or indeed regulation and you've
talked and Tony's talked about growth
you've talked you've heard me talk about
Invasion well we need regulatory regimes
that are fit for the future that ensure
that this country can be leaders in
those industries that are going to
create the jobs and the growth of the
future and having the regulatory freedom
to do that is an important opportunity
of brexit and that's my agenda and I'm
confident that that agenda is not only
right for the country but can deliver
enormous benefit for people up and down
the UK in the years to come
next the times
thank you prime minister Alex Ralph from
the times given the rising corporation
tax next year will you commit to
increasing investment allowances such as
the super deduction scheme which the
likes of the CPI and other Business
Leaders want
well Alex I completely agree about the
importance of unlocking private
investment it's one of the things that's
held our country back over the past few
decades and if we want to be serious
about driving up growth then we need to
unlock more private investment not just
in r d that I talked about in my speech
but also in capital it's something I've
spoken about in the past so that's why I
was so pleased that the chancellor in
spite of the difficult decisions that
needed to be made was able to make
permanent the annual investment
allowance now that at a very high level
of a million pounds and what does that
mean that's essentially full expensing
for 99 of British businesses there's
nothing like that that I think exists in
almost any other Advanced economy it
makes it incredibly easy and tax
efficient for companies to invest in new
equipment new Machinery new plant that
can drive up our growth drive up our
productivity and that's why it was right
that the chancellor did that but it's
also right that we continue to look at
that and see that we do everything we
can whether it's through the tax system
or otherwise to support all of you to
keep making investment in the future
growth of our country
and next Bloomberg
thank you prime minister Lizzie burden
Bloomberg
over and over we hear critical voices
coming from the business Community about
the conservative government's
performance are you still prepared to
say explicitly that the conservatives
are the party of business
thank you yes unequivocally
unequivocally you heard of my speech
it's important that government creates
the conditions
for stability
uh for making sure that we tackle
inflation but that's just the foundation
now all of us collectively need to build
on that foundation and what my role is
what the government's role is is to
ensure that we can unlock all of the
things that we want you to do and what
you will want to do whether that's
investing more in new machinery and
equipment and automation whether it's
investing in r d to create the products
and services of the future right
expanding into new markets ultimately
it's business that creates the wealth
the jobs that this country needs it's
not government that does that and I
think you've seen from my track record
as Chancellor that I stood by all of you
I stood by business because I knew how
important it was to our country I knew
how important it was to safeguarding
people's jobs and their livelihoods and
that's my track record as your
Chancellor and you can rest assured that
as your prime minister I will continue
to build on that Legacy and ensure that
we make this country one of the most
exciting Dynamic places for businesses
small and large anywhere in the world
that's my my ambition that's what I want
to deliver for you and I think we made a
very good start on that last week but
there's lots more that we can do
thanks prime minister we are going to
have a few business questions uh I've
stolen the first one I'm really sorry uh
I was praising your maze lecture earlier
this year uh and in it you talked about
the UK not having a competitive tax
regime compared to our competitors on
Innovation skills and capital allowances
thanks for stealing that question Alex
tell me do you think we now have that
competitive regime for incentivizing
skills Innovation and investment or is
there more to do
well those are exactly the right three
areas to focus on and thank you for your
kind words about the maze lecture Tony
but I talked about Capital people and
ideas and I think many of you think
about your businesses in a in a similar
way and it's right that our tax regime
but also our regulatory regime supports
all of you in delivering in those three
areas so we're definitely making
progress as we just talked about the AIA
and full expensing for 98 99 of UK
businesses million pounds permanent
nothing like that exists anywhere else
as far as we can tell enormous support
for the vast majority of businesses in
this country to invest more I think that
is not just competitive it's probably
the most competitive tax regime for
investment you can find you talked about
r d the chancellor increased the
research and development expenditure
credit the tax relief for large company
r d significantly in the Autumn
statement because as you know Innovation
drives future growth and productivity
but it's not enough just to increase the
rate we want to make sure that our tax
regime keeps up with the way that all of
you actually conduct research and what
we'd heard from Life Sciences companies
that there's more investment in cloud
computing and data to do drug discovery
that wasn't covered by our regime so we
now want to make sure that our regime
does cover that again it's something
that the vast majority of other
countries haven't done yet so I think it
gives you the confidence you need in all
of you that we take this seriously and
we'll keep delivering it but there's
always more to do right this this budget
or this Autumn statement there was a
first step the precondition is stability
and tackling inflation but we didn't
stop there even last week we started to
deliver on a longer term ambition to
make sure that this is as I said the
most attractive place for all of you to
invest in capital and people and ideas
anywhere in the world and I'm highly
confident that we can deliver that and
that's a powerful message for everybody
now we have three questions that have
come in from members and we wanted to
pick the ones that were about Innovation
your theme so Claire where's Claire
Claire Barkley who's the UK MD of
Microsoft
Claire Mike coming to you
thank you Tony thank you prime minister
um you set out a vision to be a Global
Science and Technology superpower and
what would your message be um to all the
businesses in the room and many of them
are investing very heavily in digital
and Technology as well as the role that
the public sector plays in accelerating
that and what can we collectively do
together
well thank you Claire and thanks for
everything that Microsoft does I think
in particular on apprenticeships which I
know well and I think that's an enormous
example for many to look at I think
probably three things if I may I have
three things I'd ask of you and everyone
else the first is to continue investing
in r d because that's something where we
need to do a better job of right I
ultimately it's you it's free enterprise
it's a private sector that drive growth
and I think we need to do a better job
of investing in r d the government's
going to do it but it's bit but that's
not sufficient we need all of you to
keep investing in Innovation and
prioritizing it in the way that we have
so that's the first thing the second
thing is around regulation now I think
the CBI talked about the idea of an
office for future regulation but I we
need your ideas so when it comes to the
industries of the future where you're
all working you're going to be far
faster than someone sitting in Whitehall
to see where the new barriers are or
where the regulation and aren't keeping
Pace with what you're trying to do and
so you need to come to me you need to
come to the chancellor in the business
secretary and say okay this over here in
data this over here in clinical trials
you know this over here in AI regulation
this over here in fintech and whatever
it might be uh we can't you know we will
try and do it but ultimately you're
going to know it better and faster than
we ever will so please do come to us
with those specific ideas about how to
create as I said the most Innovation
friendly future focused regulatory
regime in the world because that's what
we want to deliver for you and then the
third thing is on talent I think when I
talk to all of you the number one thing
you're talking about is Talent is how do
we get access to the skill people we
need and obviously you know LinkedIn is
a great a great place to look at that
but what I need from you is the specific
areas the pinch points that are holding
our growth back I think it's kind of
generic to say well we have you know we
have pressure in I.T jobs right but I
need to know more specifically it's In
Crowd cloud computing it's in data
analytics these are the specific things
we need and here by the way is a type of
qualification qualification we need to
fix it right we can do a one-year
conversion course or a three-month
skills boot camp and then we can work in
Partnership together to invest in people
and make sure that we fill the specific
skills gaps that are holding you and the
country back and I think we've started
that conversation but I'd like to carry
it on to make sure we deliver on it
I think the Prime Minister has just
launched the next CBI consultation so
answers please on a postcard to me we'll
give them to the PM right James Roth is
the CEO of wincampton James come on in
foreign
thanks Tony thanks prime minister
um so we're the largest uk-owned
Logistics service provider and we have
quite a lot of warehouses around the
country and in common with a lot of the
UK economy we have a productivity issue
exacerbated by labor shortages and
sparring spiraling labor cost inflation
and one of the main solutions to that is
to automate more more robotics working
alongside our people but when we look
for partners to work with to develop
those Solutions we mostly have to look
overseas particularly when it comes to
the hardware what I'm interested in is
how can we partner better with
government to help develop that sector
on the shore so that there's more of a
provision and we can work better in that
way so that's excellent question it goes
to Heart of some of the questions before
about what's the right balance between
investment and productivity and
migration now look I think there are
some really fantastic examples your
business is one right now at Lincoln
University the government's funding I
think r d working in partnership with
others to create more Automation and
fruit picking which has been an area of
challenge in the past you know Astra at
the moment are piloting use of Robotics
in uh in their factories and one of one
of my kind of most interesting visits as
Chancellor was to a lighting Factory in
the Northeast where they had taken out a
lot of the the Human Action when it came
comes to forklift trucks in their
warehouse replaced it all with robotics
and Not only was that great for
productivity it was great for quality of
output and mistakes and great for safety
of workers so I think it shows the
promise of what you can do when you get
this right and when I was talking to
them about Well I this is great how do
we spread this across the country it you
know was interesting the thing that they
focus most on was kind of management
experience with that type of technology
and the person I was speaking to had
been trained unsurprisingly by the
Japanese in lean manufacturing
techniques up in one of the other plants
in the Northeast but that's why you're
spreading best practice across the UK
through Innovations at Tony has
championed like made smarter for example
is just making sure that our businesses
have the skills they need to adopt that
type of technology I think is a big part
of the answer where we need to do more
also it's about making sure the regime
for investment is is attractive and
that's why the AIA that has talked about
the annual investment allowance full
expensing for capital investment for 98
of businesses and of course over time it
would be nice to be able to do more
that's the other piece of the puzzle
that we need to get right and then
lastly is the regulatory side and that's
where again I'm relying on you to say
we'd love to do this thing here's the
block you know can we Flex it or change
it and again we're open to doing all of
those three things because I think your
point is right if we can get that right
with more Robotics and automation then
we can drive up productivity it reduces
some of the pressure on labor creates
good jobs for people and it's something
that we lag behind in I think there was
a study from the robotics Federation or
whoever it was a couple of years ago
which showed that you know we
under-index for the amount of Automation
and Robotics even when you control for
the sectoral mix of our economy and so
that to me is actually low hanging fruit
when we talk about how do we drive up
growth we've got an opportunity there to
do it and to do it relatively quickly I
hope
Rishi you should be a chief executive
you're wasted in this job right uh let's
let's let the final question from Emma
Swan who's the CFO of ball group Emma
and you could tell us a bit about your
business you're a local business
well I'm the finance director at Bowl UK
um we extrude aluminum we're based in
leicestershire and we're classified as
an energy intensive business
so my question is what more will the
government do to support firms on energy
costs and also to give confidence and to
help us make longer term investments in
alternative renewable energy sources
ameth great that you could be here and
congratulations on what your business is
uh is doing
I know it's been tough it's the first
thing to say right if you're an
energy-intensive business over the last
six months 12 months have been
horrendously difficult and that's why
we've put in place as you know an
enormous amount of support something
like 55 billion pounds to help both
families and businesses between now and
the end of the financial year hopefully
that's made a difference to your
business uh good I can see you nodding
so I'm glad to hear that look going
forward after that given the
circumstances it's right responsible
that we adjust how that support works it
will be more targeted at those
businesses that need our help the most
and that's something that the chancellor
is working on as we speak and we'll
publish more plans in in due course but
we recognize a particular issue with a
group of Industries who are very reliant
on energy that we need to make sure we
have a plan for and I said you can
expect the chancellor to address that
but your other point was you know
looking forward what can we do well I
think actually again it goes back to
this point about investment can we
support you to make the Investments to
make your business more energy efficient
to take advantage of new technologies
that's why things like the AIA are so
important and again hopefully your
business can benefit that from that with
some of the Investments you're making I
think we need a regulatory regime that
incentivizes the creation of Cheaper
regulatory renewable energy and we're
doing that whether it's cfds or whether
it's reducing the planning time for
offshore wind turbines to from I think
four years to almost a year is the plan
those are the types of things we can do
to help solve this problem problem over
the long term and give you confidence
that this will be a country where the
energy you need is not only secure but
it is also clean and it's also
affordable and I'm confident that the
plans that we've got in place will move
us to that world because that's going to
be good for your business good for the
people you employ and ultimately good
for the country
okay everybody prime minister we are so
grateful that with everything that's
going on in your world you've not only
come up on the train to see us you've
engaged with everybody's questions and
you've set out the beginnings of a
really exciting agenda around Innovation
so on behalf of everybody here but I'm
sure you'll join me in with Applause
Rishi sunak the Prime Minister
thanks very much
we'll see you all
thank you very much everyone and now I'm
going to fill some time for you while we
reset the stage I just wanted to Echo
Tony's thanks to the Prime Minister for
coming here for talking to all of you
guys and for all the partnership that
they've given us so far look forward to
more of it what a way to kick off